hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to kindergarten now I'm
gonna try this again and this time I'm
not gonna be stupid about what I'm doing
not that I was stupid about what I'm
doing before because it was kind of the
situation where the world was kintyre
Lee against me and I didn't have any
idea what I was doing so I'm gonna go
into this world without the money that I
don't have and I'm gonna start talking
to other people hey there cutie I'm
Cindy want to be my boyfriend
sure okay that's what I like to hear and
will totally be the cutest couple in
school but first you have to do
something for us hahaha that's cute but
no it is you're gonna have to prove it
to me let's see how do I do that you see
that girl over there
that's Lily she is by far the ugliest
nastiest girl you will ever meet I want
you to take this gum and stick it in her
hair for me during morning time got it
okay I'll do it
oh yeah it's gonna be so great you'll
finally get what she deserves just like
your brother did for dumping me whoa
come find me for morning time after
you're done what happened to her brother
you haven't heard you went missing his
disappearance totally stole the Thunder
from my dog biscuit going missing I
guess everyone just cares about him more
than they do about me what you dog went
missing too yeah I brought her in for a
show-and-tell but the janitor said dogs
aren't allowed so he took her apparently
she escaped from his closet and they
couldn't find her maybe I could find
your dog instead hmm interesting
proposal I do miss biscuit the question
is do I love biscuit more than I hate
Lily you love biscuit more ah no no I
definitely hate Lily more oh yeah Lily
is actually a despicable person existant
bothers me don't worry about biscuit
just put that gum in her hair during
Martin Davin talk to me afterwards okay
all righty then
kindergarten is a vicious nightmare land
of politics and espionage
oh hello oh I didn't know the janitor
was over here hi how you doing there
City don't mind the old janitor here
just sweeping up after you silly cretins
sweepy sweepy sweepy
that's a mob ah so it is
you're also mopping the sidewalk I'll be
mopping your blood of it if you don't
skedaddle skedaddle I'm a man of my word
you're gonna kill me oh why is everyone
okay with that why is everyone okay with
that you know that's just mean and rude
and okay I'm gonna talk to Lilly first
because Lilly doesn't seem so stupid
oh um hey I'm Lilly you've probably
heard about what happened to my brother
I haven't you haven't spent all over the
news he went missing a few days ago
sorry to hear about that thanks that
makes you one of the few people that
even seems to care ever since he went
missing people either ignore me or
insult me Cindy's been trying to put gum
in my hair why I don't know but if I
were you I'd stay away from her she's
really mean thanks for the tip I guess
hello I'm Monty if you need something
come talk to me
odds are I can get it for you for the
right price what I need and what I sell
changes throughout the day so come see
me often is what's for sale uh I can get
a screwdriver got to suck her off the
janitor first steel it's weird but he's
willing to sell me the tools provided
for that's cool but I ain't complaining
it'll run your $1
okay pleasure doing business with you
okay what else you got I'm gonna get the
cigarettes cuz I need those never took
you for a bad apple there's only a
couple left in the pack but it's at a
discount you can happen for a buck just
don't go showing them to anybody it
could get us both in trouble understand
what can I do for you I'm good thank you
what do you have to say about this
conundrum I'm Jerome I don't think
enough to talk to me but every jerk all
right fine then teacher Jerome's a jerk
I'm mrs. Applegate I have been
well-endowed Oh with huge tracts of
teaching qualities you sure have
alrighty then I guess the only way to
talk to someone is by going well I guess
I could take this yeah I do yes I do
enough uh why all right fine
I'm sold what do I do all right sure
yeah okay I'll do that
although they you ain't Lilly more
yeah Lilly is a despicable person okay I
talked to nugget here whoa I'll be your
friend
what is your offering I only only have
friendship
perhaps that is all new kid needs you
may have Nuggets nuggets it signifies
our friendship thank you you're not
consumed the Nugget of friendship for
with its suggestion so it's to us our
friendship possess it good nugget we'll
see you later Brandon okay no more
talking now okay well who do I talk to
you then who do I talk to are you doing
okay all right bye then goodbye I guess
I guess this is goodbye okay hello want
some cigarettes whoa
the Robin kid so I could buy these from
Monty thanks Bunch you can have this
monster mount card it's one of my
favorites
okay okay children it's time to start
the day everybody head inside for
morning time all right yeah that's a
different way I guess I'm not gonna get
any pills this time so I'm for you to
pick your buddies this morning or you
can be sad pathetic and alone as long as
you're the best you you can be okay
doot-doot-doot not gonna put gum in your
hair oh I don't really do the whole
morning buddy thing okay fine there you
go
did you just oh you did you put gum in
my hair oh I didn't mean to Sidney put
me up to this well I don't even care
leave me alone I didn't mean to do that
let me do that hello did you do it oh my
gosh she totally did
Wow what happened what did she say did
she cry I bet she cried she cried yes
morning buddy which also makes you my
boyfriend as my boyfriend you get the
honor of playing house with me I'll meet
you over at the doll house I'll be oh
honey
wow this is weird well weird okay
welcome home husband I hope work wasn't
too hard cuz you're gonna be making
dinner tonight I have to make dinner
because I've been so busy maintaining
the house in I have you been drinking
again yes well at least you're being
honest with me and more importantly
yourself you have a problem yes dear I
want to call your sponsor and tell him
about it I also want you to give me
money to buy a new purse and handle the
trauma vsd you're causing me yes dear I
don't have the money for that
you're not you might want to reconsider
that why cuz otherwise you might get
hurt is that a knife it's my pretty pink
pocket knife don't give me somebody or
I'll be calm down I don't have enough
that's a shame you showed some promise
oh well we dumped I did I just was
trying to be a good husband I thought
that I was gonna be well alright fine
then I guess I'll sell something before
I go say hi to you alright I must sell
it no no I'm not that I don't want that
done now not that
I want to sell something I got a whole
bunch of [ __ ] but I can't sell it all
right oh no now I can't get anything
from the racks cuz I didn't get the
teacher drugs now get Kenny amazing
alright fine
nugget needs a magnifying glass but I
can't get a magnifying glass don't go
snooping around alright that oh no no no
no you can't just leave class without a
pass
oh can I use the bathroom I don't know
can you oh you are [ __ ] may I use the
bathroom of course now that you've asked
correctly here's the bathroom pass gee
thanks just be back soon ok I need to
find some oh hi not so fast there little
dude I'm gonna need to see your Hall
Pass before I can let you by
cuz my pass ok I'll let you pass but you
can't let you go any further than the
bathroom
that's fair Oh what you gonna do about
it
well nerd who's gonna do bad nerd I find
that you're big for a kindergarten Oh
for some reason I thought the music
would have changed but I guess not
hi hey what's going on there boy what's
in those bags
what bags I don't see no bags
you're kidding right oh these bags
nothing for you to worry you stupid
little head about it's bleeding oh yes
yeah bleeding thank you no I'm required
by law to say at least one bumps length
away from children at all time it's a
long story but it sounds riveting it is
but that's a deal for another time I'm
morbidly curious me too that's what got
its mess in the first place anyway I
don't think it would be appropriate for
me to tell someone of your age but it's
ok for me to see a bloody bag in a bin
right now is your our chipper young
sport here take this nickel and buy
yourself up Laura chocolate a nickel
won't cut it
what do you mean a nickel won't cut it a
nickel is gonna have to cut it or I'm
gonna cut you chocolate is more
expensive than a nickel Oh in that case
I'll let the old lunch Navy go give you
chocolate at a price you would have seen
back in my day before the whole pop
incident how about that okay good now
skedaddle
all right goodbye I guess I'm gonna get
some cheap chocolate don't wanna budge
someone must be in there all righty then
again your sewin grunting on the other
side of the door it must be yours Oh
gross this toilet is disgusting there's
no way I can use it gross well there was
no point in me coming in here well I
didn't even get a nickel out of that
what was the point of it at all hey
don't go messin around with those bags
all right fine then it's gonna be on my
way mr. janitor sir I've got me a desk
out for lunch chocolate oh you're back
yes I am I'll take that bathroom pass
now go back to your morning time okay
all righty then don't know what to do
huh okay so if I put that well yep I did
that all right while I did that I don't
know if I want to play house because I
think it's gonna end up in me murdering
being murdered because I don't have
enough money all right okay no boy oh
boy yes dear I think I left something in
the car all right boy because I don't
know if I want to do that all right
teacher can I not be Sandy's partner
hello uh okay all right okay I don't
know I would kind of want to be an
outcast loser but that'd be nice okay
hello welcome um yes dear
ah no I'm just tired no I'm just tired
oh is that a bleb sir you bet it is and
if you blow so much as a point oh one
I'm calling your sponsor I'll take the
test
good 0.3 I do this that is not be a
father
ah well while you were in prison it's
probably not yours I'm sorry I guess I
have my own set of problems to deal with
but I just I want a divorce
ah you're right this isn't working out
what do we do now go spend a night with
your mother okay I guess that's fair
I'll call you tomorrow hope we can sort
this out amicably wow that was the most
fun I've had played
wha you're gonna make a splendid
boyfriend I want you to have lunch with
me great I'll see you then what version
of house do you come from okay at least
I made it to lunch alive which is nice
hope to get to the end of the day this
time eh
hey lunch lady could I have a chocolate
si got any oh not that I got anything in
it no no no I don't that no no I got
anything else all right
ah why is it so expensive wait I'll take
the chairs I could get cheaper oh you
must be the janitors new little friend
yep
he said you were a good kid I can let
you have a charm bachlin Char Char Char
of bachlin for a nickel yeah you enjoy
that then kiddo have a nice day alright
I got chocolate bar I guess that's good
can I sell the chocolate bar or do I
need it for something huh tell ya
chocolate bar how did you manage to get
that it's almost worth its weight in
gold
emphasis on the almost I'll give you
five dollars fat Daniel it's a steel
deal alright olá buy some oh you just
got food I don't need that
alright whatever alright cool I got the
what a profit alright alright Sadie why
do I need to talk to Gator about the
bags biscuit balls
I don't wanna mess withou high I just
don't want any I don't want to deal with
you I want to be Cindy's boyfriend
oh hey boyfriend I saved you a spot go
get something to eat and come sit with
me I have a nugget I don't think you
should eat that nugget may be a bad idea
to eat that I'm gonna need then nugget
oh good I was just thinking about oh
darn it my stupid mother packed me
something that's not vegan
she knows I'm all vegan right now got
that woman's in sufferable hey sweetie
would you be a darling and go and get me
something vegan yeah you know um like I
don't know exactly what it means but I
know it's good so just ask around and
see if you can find something vegan oh
and the slop isn't vegan okay I know the
biscuit balls RV biscuit balls all right
hello Charlie why would Cindi want to
try one you're being creepy about it did
you drug it she wanted something vegan
ah all right give me the biscuit ball
for free door hey it's vegan I'll also
throw in one of the monster mod cards
okay okay
hey city it's vegan what did you get me
this thing that's vegan are you sure I'm
not sure about anything Cindy up into
this point okay I trust you munch munch
hey that's pretty good
crying reminds me of hood but uh a
feather her dog that is not vegan I'm
gonna go ahead and point out that is
that's not being being so good to me
today you're probably the most well
trained boyfriend I ever met I should
use you for something in recess I have
an idea
I'm really liking the way Lily where's
that
gum but maybe we could put something
else in there what do you mean Jerome
was telling me how the janitor has all
sorts of gross stuff in his closet okay
all right oh you don't worry about that
look what I have give the key yep
girl has her ways I'm gonna head over
and pay out the lunch lady so you can
get going on what about the hall monitor
oh that's silly boy he'll be in the
bathroom having a cigarette just don't
go in there and you'll be fine okay
listen for the bell when you're in there
the janitor will come back shortly after
it rings as soon as possible let's do
this all right
you're good to go hurry back okay I'm
good I'm good Cindy Lou Who I don't know
what I'm good for it oh I'm gonna get
that monster man card oh unscrew it give
me that oh oh you shouldn't be here it's
recess time go out and play oh well that
was too quick what happened what the
hell happened well I didn't do nothin
all righty then go play while you're
still young and fan all right what do
you got
monster Mon card whoa I don't have
enough money for that all right I don't
want anything I think I'm just gonna go
on my way well I know he didn't I don't
know why but I know he did you talking
about the principal
the murderous principal right glint in
his eyes creepy all righty then well
what did you get
see I'm not ready to show you yet I
think maybe I'm not 100% sure about that
nugget that is a gigantic hole in the
ground then you have done behold the
nugget cave it is a very deep and very
dark what secrets does it hold do you
want to find out sure Oh
[Music]
that's not what I wanted to do that's
the opposite of what I wanted to do okay
all right hello get out of here I'm busy
you don't look busy I am good uh what's
the point it's no fun being a bully one
no matter how many kids you beat up my
dad still isn't coming back a little bit
sentimental there I miss everything
about him even the way he used to drink
excessively oh yeah a breathalyzer
oh it's just like the one my mom used to
force my dad to use thanks buddy oh okay
oh this is sad
all right sad all right you're welcome
I'm sad down all right behold no I don't
wanna know I don't think I will
no one has ever not loved okay I'm not
going
oh you'll go one way or another you'll
go I don't think I'll go don't bother me
kid I'm trying to figure this out is
this riddle about these stupid duck
things fairly if you shake into the
right order something supposed to happen
what's the riddle go twice the ducks
that's farthest south then to blue
before red after return to the first
duck then blue get it wrong and you're
dead okay so yellow yellow blue blue red
yellow blue okay
okay yellow yellow whoa whoa red yellow
whoa all right okay that's weird magic
that happened they're not hundred
percent sure why what that happened and
then there's a monster mint card like
the Brown Deer yay
I'm great at what I do and stuff and
things all right so I'm gonna tell Cindy
that I don't got nothin cuz I don't I
didn't grab anything
nothin you didn't grab anything what the
hell you even good for I hope you die
we're through I'm sorry you feel that
way about me I don't feel like that's
okay all right never mind then all right
okay everyone's weird here and I don't
know how to leave how do I leave leave
well I don't know how I did it but I
think I reached a dead end ah run this
game is in early access so I think I
found a way to not get where I need to
go so I think I think that's the end of
what I can do here which is a damn shame
because I'm gonna lose all the progress
that I made so okay then I guess that's
no good so that is the end of this
episode here I'm sorry I didn't make any
more progress I just don't want to have
to die to be able to get any farther so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know how I'm doing in
kindergarten I have a feeling not very
well but I'm enjoying myself question
mark so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]